Bobbe wilcott buys his wife addy a new
house hoping to save this struggling
marriage
when a dark force invades their lives
they refuse to believe it can hurt them
but when things turn violent they must
decide to stay and fight or run risk
tearing their family apart
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay welcome back this is 13 o'clock Tom
and Jenny we're here we've got a good
show today yeah he's gonna he did the
introduction yeah you know I could do
anything good I did it sometimes don't
you know change things up let the
introduction yeah this is this is a good
episode today we got a big reaction out
of Eden Lorraine Warren yeah who knew
that somebody before like introduced an
interesting yeah according to the data
people want some more and Lorraine and a
friend of ours or an online friend of
ours army buddy of mine with the name
John are yeah John are you know he
served in Korea together not exact same
time anyway he came up with the idea
that we should talk about a haunting the
program a haunting yeah so this is kind
of like a double whammy it's a haunting
episode that has an Lorraine in it we're
talk about that it's called the dark
side and it's actually one of the cases
the Warrens never I really couldn't find
much information on this other than its
crypt okay yeah other than the episode
of a haunting that it was featured on
but the Warrens were evidently involved
I don't think they ever wrote a book
about it or I don't think it was one of
their super famous cases but they were
involved in it it could be mentioned in
some of those video interviews that they
sell yeah was it because I think they
did do like some compilations I books
like but it wasn't one of the big cases
like the conjuring or Annabelle or don't
like that where they were like a whole
book about it no but it makes this it
makes this case kind of difficult to
verify because we don't have access to
me the primary sources yeah I mean all
we have is like what the witnesses right
said on the show and you know and I
think that's I think that's probably one
of the strongest points in this case is
that the witnesses seem to be credible I
would say I kind of believe that they
believe what they're saying and it seems
sincere yeah and honestly I kind of you
know like I said most of most of these
I'm not saying that like everybody that
donal haunting is making it up and [ __ ]
like that but I'm saying that some of
them I feel like they go too
over-the-top
yeah like they're seeing this
that these people seem like they're
their [ __ ] was pretty low-key yeah
actually the haunting is actually kind
of mild now now what they're showing you
during the episode you know the
cinematography that yes of course it's
hyped but what they're actually saying
seems pretty mild yeah but before we get
into this case that we guys
housecleaning we did before we start
going on this yes is this direction
unseen hand Amanda the response to
unseen has been awesome according to the
data a lot of it is viewers yeah I then
but not all of it on the audio on
audible it's mostly audible customers I
think based on the reviews that we have
what we need though what I'd like to do
is we're looking for listeners in the UK
and in Australia
could you please contact us so we'd like
to give you some free audiobooks in
exchange for a review yeah because we
don't really have any reviews in
Australia and we don't really have any
in the UK they're selling there yes but
nobody's and I know that we have a lot
of listeners in England and Australia
that's because from the geographic
downloads at least of the audio podcast
I'm not sure about the YouTube yeah yeah
friends friends 13 o'clock on Facebook
and asked us for a free copy to
luminaria we were verified cause I've
got a bunch like all for my paranormal
books I have free audiobook codes yeah
yeah you want free audiobooks we're
going to give them out priority is
Australia and UK yeah because we need we
need reviews on those on the Australian
on you yeah yeah okay what else we owe
our YouTube show recently went over 500
subscribers yeah that's another thing if
you're listening to the podcast please
um subscribe on you on YouTube as well
to the YouTube show you'll enjoy the
YouTube show and that's a good way to
make requests because a lot of these
shows that we do or based upon requests
that we get off of youtube yeah alright
so it's a good way to contact us we're
always looking at those yeah so hooray
we went number five minutes over 500 and
people are 504 right yeah and like the
OMG audio show on projects entertainment
network whoo
project entertainment this month we are
already in the month isn't even over yet
we're already over 14,000 downloads
yeah which is incredible which is
incredible for a podcast that we didn't
really intend to do yeah we were asked
to do this show by our mom we just kind
of fell into it aspirin slowly kind of
grew into this without any kind of
advertising it's just all been
word-of-mouth and some some of you guys
have been with us from the very
beginning we really appreciate our
viewers yeah all right let's start with
this case now all right so we're getting
to this case now this case was featured
on a haunting season 3 episode 10 and it
was called the dark side the interesting
thing this is actually one of the better
episodes from season 3 I thought yeah
because like I said because it was
low-key it didn't seem overhyped or
anything like that even despite the
Warrens involvement it seemed like some
plausible [ __ ] if see applause and if
season 3 of The Haunting by the time
season 3 was rolling around haunting was
starting to get over the top if he has
to be but this is one of the standout
episodes for season 3 just because it
was more restrained yeah I thought yeah
an unusual thing about this and probably
why I had such a hard time like finding
other information about this case was
that now the people the the couple at
the center of the haunting Bobby and
Addie wilcott they were interviewed on
there rather extensively then I'm
assuming that those are their real names
the haunting they bought the the
haunting where you know where the house
that they when they bought the house in
1978 the weirdly the show does not
specify where the house is no it just
says in doing it just says New England
doing which is unusual disappointed
found everything it'll say like the city
in the in the state but this one they
just said New England and I don't know
if it's because they didn't want people
going there because you live girl is
here so because I think I mean or at
least they still live there in 2006 when
the show came out right so I don't know
if they still live there now but um yeah
so maybe they didn't want people coming
knocking on the door horn hey on a house
for a while yes
even though evidently is prison I'm on
today
or right according they had yes but they
have them should happen basically the
story went like this so this couple 1978
living with their parents they had been
living with Bobby's parents and it was
causing some problems as it will because
you know how parents are
and um you know so Adi the wife she's
trying to convince Bobby to buy a house
because they want their in place right
and she seemed to think she was pretty
kind of diplomatic about it but she was
kind of saying you know that he was kind
of dragging his feet it's like she'd
call the realtor and they'd go see
houses and he'd be like oh I don't like
that one I'm like I would like you know
he didn't really want to do it I think
later on she kind of said something
about how he didn't want to grow up or
something like that
eventually they called they got this one
house it was an old colonial and the one
they used in the episodes was kind of a
little bit small and junky looking but I
don't know what the real one was like so
finally he's kind of like yeah this this
was like nice we can do this or whatever
now the interesting thing is that the
realtor takes them to the house yeah she
wants the realtor doesn't want to go
away and give them the keys and she's
like nah I'm good ever in the driveway
yeah you guys just go in yeah make it in
there he gets in there got the bleep it
was open he didn't have to unlock it
yeah he walks in he starts looking
around starts going upstairs and a guy
comes out of the side riverstomp
upstairs who are you
yeah he's like we're with the realtor
and you know they'd already put a
deposit down on the place yeah well
Bobby did without family without teller
and I get to discuss they're like a
surprise yeah and the guy that lives
there says don't go upstairs because
well how can I buy a place if I can't I
can't look at it yeah so guys like okay
he let them go upstairs to go upstairs
and all the upstairs doors a lot are
nailed shut our nail chest he has a bus
doors open to get in to get into the
roof to see and there's vines and stuff
girl growing in through open windows so
the big that's what that's how it's
shown in the program right and they go
downstairs made
notice they see that the whole family's
living in basically one room downstairs
in the direct room with like a sheet
across the it looked like the living
room yeah like the living room there was
like a mattress on the floor wrong it
was like it looked like him and his wife
and it looked like a like a teenage
daughter or something like yeah and
they're like to me that was one of the
creepiest thing ever because can you
imagine just living in one room
downstairs yeah going to look at a house
and like you don't know what he was in
there cuz like the houses owned
obviously because they were buying it
but they didn't know anyone was home and
they go in there and all of a sudden
this like bum like pops he looked like a
bomb in the episode I don't know what he
really looked like you he comes out from
behind a sheet had the sheet across the
entrance to the living room and they've
been living in there yeah
and they had nailed on the upstairs door
shut yeah he's like what why don't you
guys use the upstairs why is it where
all the doors nailed shut and the guy
really wouldn't ask and they just kind
of looked at him like oh you'll find out
and they had a player they had a prayer
piano there that didn't work but they're
checking the place out and you know it
is you know they're going to buy it yeah
and they said it needed a lot of work
but like I said it's hard to tell I
don't know how much of a dump it wasn't
about it now the way it's shown in the
episode it makes it seem like that the
family was afraid to live upstairs
yeah and now me that maybe that wasn't
really what was happening could be that
it was so junky upstairs and the windows
were busted out the decided to nail the
door shut to keep the drafts and keep
Arab found animals out of the house it
might have been and Bill that's a
strange solution to it is a very strange
well that's the thing and and that could
be like feel like you said that could be
an alternate explanation because maybe
this family maybe they had this house
maybe they lived in a long time and they
rapport and they couldn't afford to fix
all our stuff it was an old house so
they just man yeah so they just you know
locked up the top and read everybody
stay out of there because maybe there
was without that was dangerous or
whatever but as the situation was
portrayed in in the episode it was
effectively creepy yeah because like I
said I could imagine like go and work at
houses and fish yourself sit down like
looking at you like yeah all the doors
up do it all this
so they buy the place and what happened
after that okay so they buy the place
and they start fixing it up yet
now the first thing that started to
happen you know they were both fixing it
up and they're kind of joking around
about oh it's going to be so pretty when
we finish and all this other kind of
stuff and then they're upstairs and they
here's a huge crash yeah downstairs yeah
it's not like a bunch of bring a broken
glass now the first thing they thought
was yeah they had a big mirror that was
like hanging over the fireplace and they
said oh well that must have just fallen
off the wall because they said that's
what sounded like a big huge crash yeah
so they go down there and nothing's
broken
yeah it couldn't find it they they were
to discover where that sound fan from
yeah and now the way they described it
they said the sounds they were hearing
were like really really big crashes like
it had to be something like something
breaking or something falling over and
run they go down and there's nothing
there the thing like I said the thing
that kind of makes me feel like maybe
something weird was going on in this
house is that it wasn't a type of thing
where it was just like everyday yeah
because like sometimes even on the show
they even said oh you know nothing
happened for a few weeks or nothing you
know that they noticed right because
they heard this big crash and they
thought it was weird but then they
didn't really think any more about it
when they keep fixing up the house and
everything like that
yeah interesting part about this case is
that it takes place over many years yeah
which is unusual yeah and like I said
they didn't say it was like relentless
or like it was like an adult or some of
the other shows occasional yeah it was
just like occasional [ __ ] which is why
they stayed in the house for so long and
like I said as far as I know they're
still there they were in 2006 like a few
a few months passed and they have the
house kind of fixed up and stuff like
that now Bobby is at work he's an
engineer you know addy is the house wife
which is like every other woman on the
show this is it they always stay home by
themselves I guess what it is and the
end the husband's always work the night
shift yeah like 95% were in a trucker or
he's a trucker something like that like
he's always gone at nighttime you know
coincidentally so so Bobby's at work or
something and addy has a friend of hers
named Shannon and Shannon has come over
to see the house in the evening and they
are sitting around farting around with a
broken player pan or whatever
now they hear
huge crash coming from upstairs right
they grab some shotguns going wrong up
there now see that I really love that
scene because I love the way I don't
even see where she brought that where
she got that shotgun from she had to
then she just it's like she just pulled
it right out of her ass and here's one
for me and here's one for you
crystal packing mamas in America man I
guess I just thought that was so funny I
don't have the eyes yeah I wish you got
but she's she's like you know just like
cops the [ __ ] they're just like you know
they wrap their and clear the upper
sparks before ninja-style and now it's
like it's like it's like buggy yeah well
they couldn't find anything yes did they
go there and there's nothing there's no
room up there nothing is broken and
they're just she's like with us we heard
some rap here and she's like it was
really really loud
her husband comes back he's like Iggy
girl's a tripping yes they do again 95%
of a haunting episodes always had the
dude not seeing anything and then
telling his wife she's a nice trip yeah
as the wife and you're being a woman
you're being a woman you wouldn't hear
things we can't see we can't see or hear
anything correctly is it Korea yeah I
don't even know how I live how do I keep
from walking into walls and was i eating
I can't say anything is there anything
good none of my senses work what am I
even doing here women you know yeah okay
that's how we do so the next thing that
happened was what so okay then and this
okay this part crack me up so then a few
a little bit later like a few days later
I don't think they specified Bobby is
home by himself working on the house
Addie's at the grocery store or some
[ __ ] he was upstairs working on house
yeah what art he was downstairs I think
he heard the player piano starts to play
by itself now he was upstairs okay they
just came downstairs oh that's right
okay so now now I know what you're
thinking a player p.m. that's the whole
point of a player piano Jenni it plays
by itself no no no this player piano was
broken broken and it didn't have because
you know how to play a piano and hide
behind that you have said that little
sheet music in genesis of watch collar
logogram yeah that makes it make the
noise okay well it didn't have that
right but he heard it playing hurt a
plane ran down there looked and nothing
and nothing no
there and when the iron and it wasn't
even playing right he just heard from
upstairs and got close to it and looked
at it it wasn't playing yeah and he
opened it he's like there's no you know
it doesn't work which that would be
weird
yeah that would be super creepy that was
a really effectively creepy part of that
yeah and that was the end of the player
piano they got rid of that well no what
ended episode this is what I said was
just was so funny
okay was that he heard it right and then
addy come from the grocery store and
then he says I heard the player piano
playing by itself and she's all kind of
like Chucky yeah right I was like
turnabout's fair play other but million
things Merritt men here yeah you met in
your minimum senses in your hands and
you don't know how anything air you know
Northwest so I just thought that I was
like yeah score one for the girl there
she's like yeah whatever you're not so
if you're not hear anything you're crazy
so I was like awesome go ahead okay so
then then it was like um kind of a long
gap I guess nothing exciting happens
yeah they're very vague when it when it
yeah well timeline and how much time is
passed and rightly need it I'm assuming
they're probably not writing it down to
Dayton which things happen yeah things
are just happening because I think stuff
was like kind of maybe most of the stuff
that happened at this time here was kind
of minor and stuff like that but so the
next thing that happened on the show and
they said it was a year later now they
said that they've been working on the
house they were having financial
problems obviously because those things
are [ __ ] money sucks
yeah which don't ever buy one unless you
have a lot of money I'm just saying but
so like a year later Bobby is bitching
because he's like there's no way our
electric bill could be this high how was
our electrical yeah that's right this is
a weird part of the movie he's like this
is creamy and she and then she's all
like what you're the one always leaving
the lights on but is it they're all like
you know they're all going like that
yeah so he's like alright well I'm gonna
go down to the basement to check out the
[ __ ] meter or whatever right okay now
he sees some meter and like I said I
don't know I'm only seeing what's on the
reenactment and what the guy said so I
don't know how accurate this is or
whatever but so he goes downstairs and
the meter is like going around all crazy
yeah yeah
an American power meter has a bunch of
dials it's a long series of dials I
don't know words like you know in the UK
or Australia but it's got like six a
little tiny dials but all move at
different speeds and then there's like a
big dial yet and then there's like a big
dial that moves from side to side with
moves laterally on the episode they show
basically none of the little dials
moving they're actually just vibrating
and then the main big dial with the with
the black dash on it
go on a million miles an hour yeah but
what he actually says in the interview
is different when they're showing he
says he would disconnect the power and
the meter would read the same whether
the power was on or off right which that
is that's a sign of something wrong of a
constant power drain somewhere yeah so
they were thinking there was something
wrong with the meter so what a haunting
shows you on the screen is not exactly
what the homeowner described yeah he
said quote unquote
it read the same whether the power was
on or off which is still not right right
so he calls the power company the power
company comes and checks out the meter
and they couldn't find an demeanor it's
fine it couldn't find thing wrong with
it and then he did it he said was never
never resolved so I felt like he said to
this day he doesn't not really yeah so I
don't know if their power bills
continued to be like ridiculously high
why I guess not I guess my guess not
dickin edited mention it again descended
the power bill that that particular
power bill that he complained about
we've driven them into the poorhouse
yeah so I guess it was only temporary
yeah but that's like that's a pretty
common thing in like poltergeist yeah
kind of like weird electrical anomaly
anomaly
yeah and that sometimes a poltergeist
outbreak I've never heard of it
attributed to haunted and there is a
difference for viewers that haven't been
a regular listener of the show
poultrygeist and haunting are not the
same I know I went through a poltergeist
event I've never seen a haunted
yeah although I lived in a bad house for
a while that's that's another story I
don't know if it was or not or just a
bad house that's i'ma leave that for
another time yeah you should you should
talk about that I'm one of them one of
these days I'll talk about that bad
house okay so can we call the power
company and they can't find anything
wrong with the meter and he said it
wasn't resolved now the next thing that
happened and I'm assuming this was just
like a few days or weeks later he comes
home from work or something like that
than the house by himself and the back
door keeps opening by itself right
yeah and like he sees it open yeah and
then he goes over there he closes it and
he's walking around yeah he closes any
locket and then he turns around he turns
right and he sees it open again
yeah right let me turn it back on the
door the door he opened it was like open
halfway at least what they show during
the episode yeah he doesn't actually say
that in any interviews yeah which you
know it's difficult to know we don't
have the original source interviews yeah
awarded you know of this case so they're
mainly they don't exist
yeah well not that I could finally just
just Dominion pitch isn't it called
Dominion new Dominion new Dominion
that's the company that makes a haunting
evidently only new new Dominion has the
source the source interview at the
Harris interview so so then you'll know
what was cut out right so he's like
trying to get this door and that was
funny too because he's like said I'm
gonna lock the [ __ ] out of this door and
it's like I'm still open it no I mean so
then like a defense ohm and he's like
and then and it's a difference between
locking your door locking the [ __ ] out
of it well yeah well if you're just
locking it you're just like no I'm
locking it but when you're lying to
shave you like oh you're doing it with
yeah you're doing with some
determination you know what I mean like
this door stays locked god damn it okay
that's what you're doing you're locking
the [ __ ] all right
that's what they say so add he comes
home and he's like the door piece of it
and then she said you know you left the
front door open and he's like I did not
yeah I just locked that yeah he's like
so all the doors are keep opening right
now when both of them are talking about
what the [ __ ] was with the doors why
won't they stay closed then they both
hear the player piano playing by itself
that's right that's right I forgot
then they both you now here's something
here's something that I don't think it
was actually addressed that they
couldn't keep the front and the front
door and the in the back door closed
right which may explain why the guy
nailed the upstairs door shut yeah maybe
they kept a baby they kept opening and
closing because well because that was
kind of the joke where he kept like
where Bobby kept like doing the door
he's like well I don't know why gene
maybe just nail him shut then I'm uh
yeah that's a lot people cut the doors
no jet to because they just get planning
and they probably got sick of it oh yeah
so they both you're the player piano
playing by itself so they both run in
there and there's nobody in there right
and then they're like wanted but
something weird is going on okay so the
next day she calls and has the piano
taken away because who the hell wants a
player piano just suddenly playing all
of them in the middle of the night
that's pretty creepy okay so she has a
piano taken away now a little bit later
the same realtor comes back to the house
and she says Oh some guy drove past this
house and he loves it he's willing to
give you like twice as much as you paid
right so you're gonna double your money
you can double your money yeah she says
no to it though because she thinks the
house is the glue to their relationship
yeah that was one thing they kind of
kind of went in here and and the the
haunting phenomena at that time wasn't
so frequent and it wasn't so
intimidating that they felt it was a
problem yeah I mean he said it was just
something to happen every now and that
he said he said something like you know
there wasn't anything that would warrant
pushing the panic button up yet it and
you know because like I said it seemed
like just stuff was happening every now
that it's you know like [ __ ] that
happens at our house it's like every now
and then the TV comes on every now and
then the garage door opens or something
like that it's not libraries yeah the
doorbell rings it's like it's creepy
when it happens but it only happens like
once every few months so it's not like
you're gonna like oh my god I have to
move on is David right you know it
doesn't like that now I think another
reason that she didn't want to move is
because this is when she told him she
was pregnant right yeah yeah so she was
probably like well I don't want to have
to be pregnant and move and it's gonna
be a big deal and stuff like that I
didn't say that but I'm assuming well
they would need the space - right yeah
what was the next thing the next night
now now actually I say they sugar she is
she told me she was pregnant right Neven
they skip ahead five years because now
they have a son named sterling and he
has five years old yeah we don't know
what happened during that five years
evidently nothing major nothing major
because they stayed there they didn't
feel like they were in any danger or
anything like that so the next you know
we we meet the family again five years
later their kid is some you know five
years old now they show that while Bobby
is like out digging in the yard
he's like playing
a tree or some shed on I was doing and
he comes across what they called a
headstone or a gravestone yeah now on
the episode it didn't look like a
gravestone it would be it was just like
a block of granite with like initials on
it
yeah but that says a cinderblock yeah
which to me looks more like a property
marker that's what I thought it was then
now I'm not saying that what they found
I mean what they found in real life
might have actually looked like a great
stone but what they showed on the
episode did not look like yeah there was
an inconsistency between what the
witnesses said they found in what was
shown yeah okay so and and they said
later on to that they had found more
than one right because you know they
said something about it they said
gravestones or headstones yeah plural
it's unclear what they found it was just
a stone that had initials on it yeah and
the stone said nwh so they were kind of
like I think was about I think it was a
problem it may have been a property
marker because evidently when addy went
to the county records office the next
day and looked up the property owners
like throughout history she found a guy
named Nathan Wilson Harding and WH who
had owned the property at some point so
that might have been a property marker
like just you know probably the edge of
his you know his acreage or what have
you it might not have been a heads-down
wrong but they interpreted it as it has
done whatever it looked like in real
life
and started to think oh well maybe there
are ghosts in the house and you know
maybe we should do something about it
yeah you know because of you in schools
right this might actually be a good time
to take a break yeah okay so oh yeah oh
man this is don't know yes all right so
we're going to take a break right now
and we will be back to continue talking
about the dark side yeah what for yeah
yeah well finally get down to the bottom
was this a headstone yes yes buddy
living on top of cemetery can I repay a
poltergeist anything you only move the
house down yeah okay we gotta go we'll
be right back in just a minute three
times with the ads the usual gang video
that need for gold a New York Times
bestselling authors my name is Jim more
interviews with pop culture stars and
create
some Johnson library and they don't talk
about politics for school events but
important event today I said they don't
talk about politics I suspect to make
end our rule that no particle here to
talk about politics of the beards didn't
you say they don't talk about politics
if somebody else says something we
should thank you anyone hear me about
all alone here three guys with beards
Tuesdays exclusively on project
Entertainment Network subculture corsets
in clothing is our favorite store for
unusual clothing shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95
once upon a time a madman poet in thief
known as Jonathan sick that's me
challenged himself myself to write a
story a day every day for a year by some
of them worked
some of them fed some of them were
spectacular then I did again
joining me every week for ink stains as
I do it a third time
and I will read you some of these
stories I'll talk about the process
about creativity in general writing in
specific maybe I can help ignite your
artistic adventures
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back like I said headstone
not has done we don't know like I said
they specifically referred to them as
headstone and that's what they thought
they were so they show property markers
but they shared a property marker so I
don't know
so they started thinking well maybe it's
a ghost the house is haunted or
something like that now a couple days
after that Bobby's at home by himself
doing laundry which usually women do on
a haunting became on every single
episode I read a blog post about this if
you go to my blog goddess of hellfire
I wrote this really long and it's pretty
funny if I do say so myself but I would
like all the like five crazy things you
see on every episode of haunting I swear
to God 95% of episode of on they have a
woman carrying a laundry basket around
yeah and it says they're doing laundry
at every single after that I'm one woman
both of this I guess that's woman's job
goddamn it so I like yeah that not only
did this episode have the wife turning
it around going you didn't hear that
player be in it you imagined it but they
also showed a dude doing laundry I was
like well that's very progressive of
this but so he's doing laundry laundry
from and then all of a sudden a box of
laundry detergent flies off the top of
the counter giddy right yeah I don't
even know if it any were to just go I
think it's just kind of flu but my back
yeah I did and like hit on the floor you
know it was like [ __ ] you're walking the
TARDIS there yes I'm Chu man yeah and
the way the way it was actually shown
during on the episode of it it looked
pretty cool they definitely had it on a
wire yeah but it would have been
traumatic had that really been the way
no good had that really been the way it
went down
we don't know if it was just a laundry
detergent box fell but it looked like it
in the in the episode what they showed
you that look like a laundry box was
strong lingerie under different yeah it
like blew across the right here but I
mean that I'm not pretty out of been
freaked out too
uh yeah yeah yeah anything flying around
by itself is generally not not a good
thing so at this point they decided well
this is throwing laundry detergent
around now and like throwing stuff so we
could throw bigger things which is what
you generally would assume so they said
okay we're we're going to call a priest
to come bless the house now they were
Lutheran's evidently and they had a
regular priest because they went to
church I guess so they called a Lutheran
priest now adentro an exorcism kind of
deal so it's just like the Luther
kind of like well we can just come bless
your house that's about all we can do so
right so we'll just come and do that
yeah bless blah blah blah and that was
it
yeah they just gave it a blessing yeah
cuz I guess that's like I said that's
all yeah I don't think they really get
anything
well yeah here's the thing it's like
after that happened now this is how they
should own the episode like the night
after they had the priest they're you
know they're like well do you think it
works and stuff yeah it seems like
better in here and stuff like that and
all of a sudden crash downstairs again
yeah they here no big huge crash crashes
downstairs at the one he said he'd send
what a sonic boom oh yeah no that was
later that was later so there's a common
occurrence in this house is huge crash
huge crashes and then they can't find a
gift card with it cause it right so they
go downstairs and they don't find
anything so now at this point they kind
of feel like well maybe ok the priest
came is lessons didn't seem to do
anything the wife and the kid go off to
the in-laws for a week I think like they
stayed away for a week so Bobby was home
by himself he was I think the night
before the wife and kids were supposed
to come back he was sitting upstairs and
he heard a huge crash like he said
sounded like a sonic boom yeah I said it
sounds like a jet flying up breaking the
sound barrier 100 feet over the house of
the house week and he heard it I guess
it was up in the attic right because
that's where he went so so he grabbed
his 45 he graduated Bible he grabs it
and the 45 was sweet 1911 and he had one
of those was for sweet gum yeah so he
goes up to the attic with it and he's
like I don't know I think it's but it's
funny to me I guess when you when you
know your house is haunted and you hear
like a scary noise in your house and
then they just grab a gun I'm like what
are you gonna do you know shoot the bolt
there goes kind of like a talisman you
know I make you feel better you make you
feel better feel better yeah cuz I'm
like I'm not going to do anything well
hey the Chinese doing these firecrackers
chase away evil spirits spirits when you
fire off a few rounds yeah I'm not going
to be like oh can I go but I'm out of
here
yeah I guess so but then again deterred
the Bible and like you know exercises
tries to exorcise the attic or whatever
yeah didn't work no not really
ok so a D and sterling come back the
next day and he says to her you know
it's getting worse and not on
what we're going to do about it and
stuff like that and then either that
night of the following night ad he's out
in the yard at night looking for the dog
like calm dog or whatever and she hears
like a look at evilly sounded whisper
like saying her name
yeah like calling her for his backyard
she's on the back here like once or
twice it called her name right and she
freaks out and runs back inside now
because at this point is the haunting or
whatever was seems to be escalating they
feel like well let's move the kid into
our room because you know they were
afraid something bad would happen so the
kids sleeping in their room on his
little Cod or whatever
now addy wakes up in the middle of
nights like she hear something weird
and then she wakes up and she sees a
figure yeah standing by the bed shows
jet-black just outline yeah she said a
jet-black man yes he said it was like a
figure yeah and she said she saw it in
the room and now on the episode they
showed it like right next to the kids
bed but she just said by the bed so I
don't know if it was their bed or
whatever she said she felt the presence
and then she saw the figure that was
kind of like the final straw like she
actually saw the thing everything like
that so they go for help so now there is
a big girl yeah who are you gonna call
and then one that they're gonna call him
around wash well we see what caused that
wreck ooh there we go look at human
rectal I knew I was going to use that
again and I'm day oh yeah so I don't
really know if they had the Warrens
recommended to them or if they knew who
the warrants or anything like I said
this was yeah this is the 83 at this
point when the courts in the story is
delivered to us or murky we don't know
how they got a hold of the warrants but
then again we talked about the warrants
before the warrants can get a hold of
you you do either you want or not a
warrant not show up yeah I mean he got
dead drop style pushing suckers outside
away
come on in HoN and add a bully his way
into a case yeah I respect it like a
crusader
I definitely and I think we mentioned
that on the warrant but I definitely do
think I don't think they thought of
themselves as obnoxious even when they
was investigated if you could they
thought they were helping you appeared
on Ed Moran's radar they'd show up if
they had to yeah okay but apparently I
don't know if they showed up to this one
uninvited did not even but I think they
found like they did yeah it sounds like
they were called which is which is maybe
why the warrants didn't make a huge deal
out of this case because maybe they
didn't they were in control of it there
weren't the ones that initiated the
contact like that the ones showed up and
they had one of their trainee
demonologist because they have some of
those this one was named Richard Jackson
that's probably who heard about the case
we got the warms on my Tibetan yeah we
don't know I mean they have mother
actually he's on the air the Jacksons
are on the episode you can see what you
got yeah Lorraine Warren's on their tail
you're talking a little bit it was
already dead by this time members uh
yeah well he died the same year that
this came out of it were drastic yeah so
okay so the warrants start looking
around the house and predictably because
it's the warrant Jamin it's a demon king
so Lorraine is going around the house
now she's now the back door that that
Bobby said you know we used to open
quarters all the time by itself she's
using her psychic powers or whatever and
she's by the back door and she says oh
it feels hot right here this is a poor
that's right I forgot that's where the
demons are coming in the back door
I got sounded dirty but that's not how I
remember and the fun funny part is that
what was the what was their little
understudy's name again Richard Jackson
yeah Jackson mentioned least they show
Jackson running around calling up like a
doing a blessing that's centered around
the powers and principalities that's
later them yeah is that later yeah I
always like it when they bring up their
powers and the principalities because
they usually have no idea what they're
talking about they're not Bible scholars
yeah yeah but you know dr. price dr.
price straighten him out or what the
powers of okay go ahead well I mean
considering this whole exorcism thing is
just like cold out of our asses Maria
Lorraine says of course to support all
those demons blood loss and even though
even though like at this point
even though like yeah they've seen a
black figure yeah the door but it didn't
seem like anything super demonic was
going on you know wasn't like the walls
were bleeding or piece of nothing like
that no our people were getting
possessions you know so far if I was if
I were on this case all right so far I
would just say it was a minor on yeah
that's something like residual line
because like I would never lay not jump
to this demonic information and the
thing about like seeing a black figure
in a bedroom at night I wouldn't
necessarily attribute because the first
thing I would think was sleeper Allison
it's not going to be much of a demon if
it takes eight years to make that crime
crash and do a few and that's on a day
player piano voice right it's like that
it's creepy like silica is creepy but
like I said that's like [ __ ] that
happens at our house right I would never
think that that was a demon I'm not
gonna I mean I'll boil demons anyway but
I'm just saying you know if it doesn't
warrant I don't believe in demons as
delivered yeah you know has described no
but like I'm saying even this case a
maker our content goes back to the
powers of Brenda body well that's
another issue we'll talk about that and
I mean maybe they left some of this out
like on the episode but it just seems
like the [ __ ] that had happened up to
this point did not warrant the warrant
didn't warrant the one involved is all
I'm saying
and the funny thing is that when the
rain comes in session reportedly of a
demon yada yada Bobby says in the
interview says what we didn't really
believe them right I don't blame him
well yeah not not enough happens that's
that is I this demon okay right
evidently the will cots are like well
should we move and then the Warrens were
like yeah well if it's a demon then if
you move then it'll just following you
so there's no point so you might as well
stay here okay
ed Warren says well we have to do an
exorcism on the house but we have to get
permission from the Vatican because you
know Catholic Church man it's like all
red tape yeah you can't just get a
exorcism on short or yeah you can't just
walk around a house with a Bible and in
events unless you have authorization god
dammit what happened it was happening at
a time where the character didn't want
to do that stuff anymore well yeah
because they didn't believe a bad video
either getting a bad reputation they're
bringing it back though
they're bringing they're bringing the
demonology yes I find that I've heard
that yeah it's kind of getting us back
into it maybe it should probably want
money at a heavy I'm probably just
waiting to spread it faith well yeah
well that's what I mean when directly
wrestling on my central South America is
like that that's right because if not
then the Macumba priests will get that
in candle blade Santeria yeah I'll
handle that and you really I think the
Catholic Church would rather handle it
yeah non-christian religions handle it
yeah cuz you get to do it right well as
credit to and they don't want I'm
depending on kind of layer my own book
print uh priests seeing all the credit
yeah no because then that would make
them up that would be their God right
well yes they're not really gods but I
know it's level each one is builder pro
the program so okay so ed says we're
going to contact the Vatican but it will
probably take a while because you know
the Vatican dude no Tories for dragging
their feet on exorcism permission latest
said later that they're like okay fine
so contact the Vatican or whatever so
then later that night evidently like
Bobby is sleeping and he wakes up in the
middle of the night and he thinks that
he's covered in brooches yeah it's an
interesting scene in the programs as mad
as a gas card giant yeah I'm not he
didn't say like exactly what they were
but you know he they weren't they're
like when he woke up he was about the I
mean that she's like that a bad dream
yeah like with the clothes you know and
but although I thought we were when we
were watching this episode Mike last
night for this program I was like you
know what I was like if you woke up in
the mill and I said you recovered a
verse I don't care for the dream and I'm
I'm getting the [ __ ] out of area and
it's funny because I'm not like afraid
of creepy crawlies like I don't mind
spiders on my lizards but cockroaches
grossed me the [ __ ] out I don't know why
it's bright and I'm from Florida they're
everywhere
and especially ones that fly yeah that
and like every now and then like one
will get into the house and I'll just be
like nope mom I got a chase you got a
thing but you know that's what happened
at Florida where we live in the middle
of the swamp even though you're in a
gated community you're still in a swamp
because that's what was here yeah and
those little things can get underneath
the tightest door yeah they can like
scooting on flies but I have shown us in
surviving Florida you have to have your
own big stockpile of insecticide three
months you pose your friend around yeah
you have to do the whole perimeter of
the house you have to do it like a few
times a year we're off ending on how
strong the [ __ ] is that you uh that you
use but so okay so he wakes up he thing
he's covered in birches and he evidently
this was upsetting to him and he thought
it was a real experience I don't know if
it was a dream or anything like that but
he's you know thought he comes which
really govern emerges so they feel like
oh well maybe we should call the
warrants back and see how that Vatican
thing is going now interestingly on the
show at this point they said okay the
warrants were quote-unquote unavailable
working on another case well I'm
guessing I don't know I was just kind of
amused by that I didn't have a cache to
slide out maybe not I don't know well I
know I've heard that they charge travel
expenses that people miss whose cases
they work on like I don't think they
charge them anything other than that but
they make them pay like for their plane
tickets or whatnot but since this was in
New England and I think that the
warrants are from Connecticut so
probably local so yeah it's probably not
far from where they were so the Warrens
were unavailable so instead they call
Richard Jackson who is the Warrens
little buddy and he comes and does
espuma gation yes litigation a Simone
irrigation has stopped but not what tell
us what it is well it looked to me it
just looks like kind of like a quantity
exorcism which which is waving incest
around and all that show it's the same
tomato smoke application yes okay fog
refer yeah and apparently that's
supposed to get the demons out because
demons can't stand the kids yeah oh no
why it's like you're like I said it's
like it's kind of like when you have
citronella candles at your backyard
barbecue to keep the mosquitoes away
right it's kind of so you know it's
Sakuma Gatien subscribe it sounds like
the citronella candles of the paranormal
world so he comes in and this is where
he was talking about the principalities
yeah
yeah okay now it's not time for me to
explain you get explosive findings
alright the Abrahamic faiths oh and of
course there are three of them at least
three major branches you know Islam
Judaism and Christianity they all kind
of give a different description of what
demons are in fact in Christianity and
probably better to describe this more
from a Christian standpoint because it's
Christians involved in this story the
Bible the Old Testament and the new
disagree on what a demon is in the New
Testament Jesus refers to casting Jesus
cast demons out of possessed people and
needs to deaf people were living in
graveyards those demons leave the man
and they go to some pigs and then they
jump off a cliff what's really being
described there is spirits of the Evil
Dead all right not angelic beings that
if fallen angelic beings in the Old
Testament in Genesis the sum the story
the first story Nika probably is
interpreted as a demon story is that the
sons of God find the daughters of men to
be beautiful they crossbreed with them
and they create the Nephilim and the
same sons of God that did this ended up
being chained in the earth you can
interpret that as a demon but that's
actually angels being in chained in the
earth now in another part of Genesis
Genesis to talk about the powers and
principalities they're talking about
angels basically but angels in the Old
Testament are not really all that good
all the time you see what you did what
you have is you have el shaddai and his
sons and in other versions of the Old
Testament like from the Septuagint I
think there was 72 of these sons one of
them was Yahweh another one was Bale
another one was Moloch and all the other
gods that are mentioned in the Old
Testament never did it say that these
other gods don't exist it just says
don't worship them well each one of
these got a sons of God chose a tribe a
Canaanite tribe Yahweh chose
tribe of Israel Molech chose his own and
then you know Vail chose another tribe
but these were all Canaanite tribes the
Israeli the tribe of Israel was a
Canaanite ride and you know they were
called the powers and principalities
each one of these sons of God was given
a tribe and a nation to rule over that's
what they're talking about powers and
principalities and them you know the
Greeks same as a Greek concept of Archon
which kind of translates to sky demon
things like that don't possess people
why would it possess a person the kind
of demons referred to in the New
Testament or the kind of Jesus was
throwing out those are basically souls
of evil that that's why it's taking
place in a cemetery that's what's being
described as two different things well I
always kind of thought and especially
nowadays and on shows like a holiday or
stuff like that because they kind of
throw possession always possess a
possessed and then all the other kind of
crap if I was a demon you know just say
why would you waste your time doing that
kind of petty [ __ ] well you would
that's what I mean there's no agreement
in these old scriptures of what a demon
is now my source and what I just told
the audience that I didn't come up with
this my source is dr. Robert ed Bryce he
got two doctorates in this he knows all
these religions and you can check him
out on the Bible geek all right he'll
tell you really what a demon is we had
him on our show yeah it was like one of
our one of our command I recommend that
you haven't heard that our biblical
mythology program with dr. Bryce you
should listen to them a good primer yeah
so the guy comes and does a superb
migration or whatever yes get rid of
more towns or souls of the you've ever
do so then a couple days later uh
Richard Jackson you know the Warrens
little buddy he comes back to the house
to check on the family make sure
everything's okay now while he's there
evidently the Wilcox kids sterling
starts to choke to death
he's like upstairs and like I guess he's
up there with his dad and then and then
Bobby starts yelling and stuff like that
and the kid is not breathing
now they don't specify whether he was
choking on a thing like he was choking
on a toy or a piece of food or like that
he just stopped breathing for a reason
yeah
I was kind of suspicious that he never
really told us the symptoms what it was
yeah they just said well he's not
breathing so while reading I was kind of
assuming well that might not have
anything to do with paranormal anything
that might be he was just playing with
his trucks and a wheel came off on each
other although my parents who were the
witnesses seemed seemed to be relieved
they seemed to think that it was
something paranormal yeah I mean now
they did call it cut something out like
they did call 9-1-1 obviously but then
like Richard Jackson comes at Sara says
it's a demon attack yeah
daemon say you know what like Igor
instead of calling 9-1-1 which is what a
normal person would do but I did call
number one fit to be to be fair and so
he says a demon act so he starts like
doing the exorcism [ __ ] over and putting
like sacred salt on amherstia sound like
that and apparently the kids like starts
breathing again any time yeah before
then they didn't show to ambulant like
that so a minor
the kids were covered what they call
rendered alert and they have to do it
will actually serve the mind yeah so
then yeah at that point like after that
happened the the Wilcox did attribute it
to paranormal causes yeah whether it was
or not I don't know so they sent a kid
to the grandparents and then the Warrens
come back yeah and they said okay well
it's targeting your kid now so we can't
wait for the Vatican because at this
point the Vatican still hasn't given
their permission so they always said
we're just going to wing it and we're
going to do an illegal exorcism right
and they call Bishop McKenna yeah this
is good easy he's a piece of work he's
like don't like and I don't like to pick
on people's appearances and stuff like
that but he's so odd-looking well he's
dead he's dead now he doesn't affect of
mine he's a character of Star Wars
he really does he's got a very very long
phage and like these weird
ears that kind of stick out at the top
of their like kind of Spock ears right
yeah he looks like Adam Hanson character
you seem very pious I'll give you
arguing that you see what very pond it's
actually quite famous um in Catholic
circles like as an exorcist and stuff
like that and I was going to mention it
we probably do a show on this someday
but he was also involved in the Merle
family haunting which is Warren's Rossa
which was kind of a famous haunting they
made a TV movie called the haunting eyes
of like a haunted rather
and I think it was in the 90s eighties
or not I made one but it was a pretty
famous that wasn't with the pig rape and
all that other kind of yeah yeah yeah I
remember I told you about that year and
it was it that's in my book the unseen
hands there that that was a little the
the early details of it were kind of
believable and then it just went flying
off the rail kind of thing now
hi Eddie it's like a pre work visit it's
like one of the biggest prerequisites in
being an exorcist
yeah tradition has it that a guy who's
really pious hadn't committed enough
sins for this demon to attack because
it's you know just like I will be
Exorcist attack is psychological yeah an
extremely pious person would have the
confidence and the faint you need to
confront evil all right because this is
a piety is a great virtue but there are
other traditions that say exactly that
evil itself has a virtue to you just put
a badass in there and can do without
sometimes evil can destroy evil also
yeah that's kind of interesting I never
looked at it that way I know all don't
even think of the greatest evils of all
mankind you don't say like okay the the
banoffee right they weren't really
destroyed by good
alright the United States and the Soviet
Union didn't go there drop flowers on
those people they drop bombs off well
they were defeated by more evil right
were just killed you know and that's
that's a virtue in its own well that I
was going to say I said any thought was
kind of funny because in the reenactment
of the exorcism when Bishop McKenna got
there they actually got kind of a
normal-looking guy before him I'm
surprised they didn't get maybe it looks
like it's someone from labyrinth or
something so I like they don't want any
kind of looks like a Jim Henson's Gary
Lucas but with their ears and it all
been so long as I was lucky and he had
kind of a muffiny voice sorry he's dead
now but it's you know talking bad about
today oh okay not me anything like a
nice man oh yeah hey I just where the DA
is stranger
he's just strange-looking but um kind of
had an eerie eerie presence John yeah
and he was cute spooky he should have
been in like movies yeah like playing
action because I believe that [ __ ] in
the in the reenactment the guy they had
playing him he comes to do the exorcism
he's getting his little like purple sash
out or whatever and he's like I don't
foresee any problem
I got this [ __ ] handled you know it was
like that kind of thing and I thought
that was very funny yeah so like the
remainder of the program and this kind
of happened a lot a lot of haunting
episodes in later seasons it's like
really the last 10 or 15 minutes and
[ __ ] episode would be the exorcism and
usually nothing happened
no it was just like they would
dramatically film people walking around
the house
yeah and lay chill expression and facial
expect my god oh my god over there over
there lights flashing and [ __ ] like that
and like how shaking and like nothing
was really happening be sure what we
recorded is that the wife from the case
Eddie Eddie said she almost blacked out
yeah she said our shows like that but
that was it like other than that like
the wood they were film it like I said
they're walking up the stairs and the
music's all John young like that and I'm
like nothing going on right so that's
pretty much the end of the case
pretty much yeah when she ends the case
okay so what's the deal like I said and
apparently the exorcisms official
McKenna did was immediately effective
yeah because oh that's right this is a
great part of a great part yeah it said
like a fog and lifted a big weight came
off of them the house felt like there
wasn't anybody in it but them yeah and
then Lorraine Warren will they all start
smelling roses
and Lorraine warns us that's the odor of
sanctity smell that smells like roses
what you're smelling is the order of
sanctity it's a sign of God's presence
the end of a successful exorcism I'm
totally putting Manatee every day ha ha
ha ha owners exiting odor and we're
sitting there saying you know like I
bent Lorraine Warren she has like a
little boy a little wild rose oil ha ha
ha ha
this is owed to owner - thank you yeah
and you have and she just sprays that
like surreptitiously at the end of every
music no God's present sounds like rose
that was what came to mind yes that you
could say that well yeah and everyone
report was not everyone but I might
neighbor
I've heard that report at the road and
smell I bet you you could go back into
the seance fine arts of the seance yeah
you can find out that they were using
that - sheesh back in the early nineties
little scented things yeah I - that on
your person you oh yeah of course you
what it was just taking like a little
bit and rose oil is like super cheap you
can buy that anywhere so I think that's
what they were doing
Lorraine I'm not gonna call you on that
little bit I'm really wink to your
summary with I I'm not really buying
tell you what's that
alright well ok so it was a really good
episode I yeah like I said they seemed
like a kind of believable couple I
didn't believe demons or nothing like
that but all the nice on the minor [ __ ]
that happened here that I could buy that
yeah I actually uh I actually believe
the case but I think it was just a minor
object and then I think the warrants got
involved and became any demonic and yeah
or not now the odor of sanctity smaller
as you need probably Wow
so anyway okay so we're getting to the
end of the show we went like way too
long about this because we just have to
yeah so we hope you enjoyed this other
episode we'll probably do more haunting
episodes at some point in the future
because these are kind of fun to get a
responder upon their fun zoom as needed
they're actually they're kind of easy to
do because
have something well because we have to
talk about we have all the episode yeah
and we have something that we can just
kind of focus in on and go yeah you know
did someone give them an analysis this
one's kind of a little bit harder
because there's not a lot of information
about like what really happened
quote-unquote because like sometimes
it's interesting to go oh well on the
episode this happened but then it
realized this happened or whatever right
there's only one source and this yeah
this is pretty much they just had them
talking and I don't know how they got
edited or whatever so I you know that's
why we kind of is not even really about
this case outside of this episode yeah
not that I know of and left like I said
it's been some of the warms archives or
so yeah I've got that they're not
releasing to the public at least not for
free yeah well I've been chance to
divide some of their stuff you can if
you want I don't think any over here
control over my no no I'll let you buy
that way don't know I you didn't like
that okay I thought I wouldn't think
less of you if you did well it wasn't a
money issue without I just I just
thought I just gotta admit that ed is a
fantastic storyteller yeah yeah yeah I
think he's kind of you know he's
interesting yeah do I believe it I'm not
all of it no yeah and like I said we
still need to do it but I think there is
something to some of what weather
because I know that they were on some
cases that I considered to be actual
cases yeah and eventually like I said
we're definitely going to do a show
about their werewolf case oh yeah
actually we actually promised to do that
yeah I finally want to do like a
werewolf man I love werewolf okay so
anyways hope you enjoyed the show and
like I said as always if you have any
other recommendations or shows you want
us to just drop a comment in youtube or
on our facebook page or whatever yes and
please sub to the YouTube show yes
please subsidy even even if you're a
listener of our project entertainment
network audio podcasts and you know just
subscribe to the YouTube show so you
have people and don't forget if you're a
listener in the UK or Australia and
you'd like some free audiobooks we would
love to get some reviews from you yes
that would be awesome that would help us
out so just contact I have a million
places you could you could contact me
just you know find be somewhere I'm on
Twitter Facebook I'm everything that
we'd have to see their Facebook profile
to make sure that they're in those
countries
kind of you yeah sure lives video yeah
don't try don't try to define who okay
so oh and sister since the name of this
episode with the dark side you know what
weeds I kind of avoided a direct see you
offered
yeah dark Bismarck's yeah go for it
alright so here we go
see you guys next Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Music]